it may be to linger on the point of
leadership I think it's one of the first
times you were really a leader and
you've led many very successful teams
since then what does it take to be a
good leader I would say I'm most of them
just take credit for the work of others
right that's that's very convenient than
that because I can do all these things
myself I'm an engineer at heart so I I
care about engineering so so I I don't
know what the chicken and the egg is but
as a kid I loved computers because you
could tell them to do something and they
actually did it
it was very cool and you could like in
the middle of night wake up at 1:00 in
morning and switch on your computer and
what you told you to yesterday it would
still do that was really cool
unfortunately that didn't quite work
with people so you go to people and tell
them what to do and they don't do it and
they hate you for it or you do it today
and then you go a day later and you stop
doing it so you have to so then a
question really became how can you put
yourself in the brain of the of people
as opposed to computers and into the
computers as super dumb then so dumb if
if people were as dumb as computers I
wouldn't wanna work with them mm-hmm
but people are smart and people are
emotional and people have pride and
people have aspirations so how can i
connect to that and that's a thing where
most of the airship just fails because
many many engineers turn manager believe
they can treat their team just the same
way akin to your computer and it just
doesn't work this way it's just really
bad so how do how can i how can i
connect to people and in terms of as a
college professor the the wonderful
thing you do all the time is to empower
other people like your job is to make
your students look great that's all you
do you're the best coach and it turns
out if you do a fantastic job is making
a students look great they actually love
you and their parents love you and they
give you all the credit for stuff you
don't deserve since it all my students
were smarter than me all the great stuff
invented it stem purposes he has stuff
not my stuff and they give me credit and
say oh Sebastian but just making them
feel good about themselves so the
question really is can you take a team
of people and what does it take to make
them to connect to what they actually
want in life and turn this into
productive action it turns out
every human being that I know has
incredibly good intentions I've really
never really met a person with bad
intentions I believe every person wants
to contribute I think every person I've
met wants to help others it's amazing
how much of a urge we have not to just
help ourselves but to help others so how
can we empower people and give them the
right framework that they can accomplish
this if in moments when it works it's
magical because you'd see the confluence
of people being able to make the world a
better place and driving enormous
confidence and pride out of this and
that's when when my environment works
the best these are moments where I can
disappear for a month and come back and
things still work it's very hard to
accomplish but in where networks is
amazing so I agree very much it's not
often heard that most people in the
world have good intentions at the core
their intentions are good and they're
good people that's a beautiful message
it's not often heard we make this
mistake and this is a friend of mine
exhorter token is that we we judge
ourselves by our intentions in others by
the actions and I think the the biggest
skill I mean he answered looking valley
by fellow engineers I have very little
empathy and and and I kind of befuddled
why it doesn't work for them the biggest
skill I think that that people should
acquire is to put themselves into the
position of the other and listen and
listen to what the other has to say and
they'd be shocked how similar they are
to themselves and there might even be
shocked how their own actions don't
reflect their intentions I often have
conversations with engineers where they
look hey I love you doing a great job
and by the way what you just did has the
following effect are you aware of that
and then people would say oh my god not
I wasn't because my intention was that
they'd say yep I trust your intention
you're a good human being but just to
help you in the future if you keep
expressing it that way then people just
hate you and I've had many instantly
would say oh my god thank you for
telling me this because it wasn't my
intention to look like an idiot was
maintained
to help other people I just didn't know
how to do it very simply by the way
there's a no-fail carnegie 1936 how to
make friends and how to influence others
has the entire pipe or just read it and
you're done and usually apply it every
day and I wish I could I was good enough
to apply it every day but it says simple
things right like be positive remember
people's name smile and eventually have
empathy like really think that the
person that you were hate and you think
is an idiot is if you just like yourself
it's a person who's struggling who means
well and who might need help and guess
what you need help of reasoning spoken
Stephen Schwarzman I'm not sure if you
know who that is but you so he says I'm
a list no but he said sort of to expand
on what you're saying that one of the
biggest things you can do is hear people
when they tell you what their problem is
and then help them with that problem
he says it's surprising how few people
actually listen to what troubles others
yeah and because it's right there in
front of you and you can benefit the
world the most and in fact yourself and
everybody around you by just hearing the
problems and solving them I mean that's
my my little history of of engineering
that is while I was engineering with
computers I didn't care at all what the
computers problems for just I just
volumize everyone to do it and people it
doesn't work with me
you've become the mean say to do AI do
the opposite
you